[Musik]
etwas glaubt willkommen beim neuen video
ja im heutigen video wie bin ich dann
noch mal daraufhin können genau zu
erfolgen dass es heißt ja eigentlich
immer so ja beschwert ich mal nicht weil
du ein junge bist mädchen haben viel
mehr probleme wir haben zum beispiel
unsere tage
wir müssen auf dem klo immer viel länger
warten als ihr wir sind einfach mädchen
und keine jungs den jungs in iq und
sowas halten und ich werde ja nicht
alles wie wenig wichtig hinsetzt würde
und so ein paar sachen war miteinander
vergleichen würde
und jetzt war so naja vergleich erstellt
habe und die zeigt euch heute macht und
dann sehen wir mal ob mädchen wirklich
viel mehr probleme haben als jungs lob
sogar schon
und bevor die es hier los geht würde ich
mal sagen wenn ihr bock auf den zweiten
teil also wenn euch das gefällt während
ihr es schaut dann lassen wir noch nach
oben da ich würde sagen bei 15.000 dax
machen wir das und jetzt viel spaß
aja und folgten auf jeden fall bei
snapshot ganz wichtig so wir fangen wir
mit punkt nummer eins an das habe ich
gerade auch eigentlich schon
angesprochen das mädchen clou ist ja
irgendwie immer überfüllt das ist
einfach ein phänomen für mich ich meine
das dauert doch jetzt keine 20 sekunden
länger kurz einmal die hose runter zu
ziehen und sie dann wieder hoch zu
ziehen anstatt einfach nur den
hosenstall aufzumachen und den
rauszuholen und dann vom spiel klappt
kommen egal heute kann ich direkt sein
also ich meine so die hose
runterzuziehen um sich hinzusetzen aufs
klo dauert auch nicht viel länger als
einfach nur den schwanz herauszuholen
anstellen zu müssen und trotzdem ist die
schlange zehn meter lang
das verstehe ich nicht so dafür habt ihr
glaube ich meistens eine toilette die
einfach einen toilette ist und nicht ein
steg wo vor zehn milliarden kaugummis
drink leben und immer wenn man auch
spielen drückt die hälfte raus schwimmt
das ist schon manchmal so auch meine ist
kaum wahrscheinlich schon so viele
kommentare von will ja wir müssen das
nur auf talent machen und das noch unter
snow und das restaurant das nur unter
frauen das nur unter snow
und das noch und das noch in das noch
dass er echt ok dann würde ich mal sagen
wir machen weiter und zwar mit folgendem
um ihr seid in der schule es ist mega
langweilig müsste aber plötzlich an die
tafel und als junge hat man ja ein
gewisses genital in der hose wir nennen
dieses genitalis muss schweizerin weil
meine eltern sind gerade hier oben sonst
denke ich wird er deswegen jetzt haben
es einfach mal
chantal immer das gleiche irgendwann mit
so lustig so entstand teil denkt die 40
com jetzt hast du bock jetzt spannend du
dich mal an und sorgt dafür so eine
kleine beule in der hose und jeder sieht
das ist doch ein eindeutiges jungs
problem ich mein mädchen so kommen als
wenn einfach die hose plötzlich feuchte
das habe ich noch nie gesehen also was
kann bei euch im unterricht passieren
ich würde sagen bei dem klo punkt haben
vielleicht so ein bisschen die mädchen
gewonnen weil es einfach jemanden lange
schlange ist aber bei diesem punkt haben
eindeutig wir gewonnen weil das größte
problem für uns jungs und jetzt kommen
wir auch schon zum nächsten problem und
zwar wenn die haare von jungs einfach in
einem tag x scheiße aussehen oder halt
auch einfach an jedem tag so wie zum
beispiel meine steht ja zurzeit wirklich
sehr sehr oft in den kommentaren er als
sehr nahe sind scheiße erlebst du siehst
mal wieder voll scheiße aus kommentar
hat 1280 likes alex pass mal auf du
siehst mit den zurückgekämmten haaren
aus wie ein spanischer pornodarsteller
124 likes moment mal wirst du die
spanische pornodarsteller aussehen ok
egal folgendes jungs haare man kann
damit nichts machen die sehen einfach
scheiße aus aber mädchen können sich
diesen dutti oder wie das heißt dieses
kleinen teil hier so rein dass ihr
einfach so ein ball ist so was wisst ihr
als einfach die haare nehmen und das
wird dann hier oben so zusammengeknotet
und dann ist das hier das sieht
eigentlich cool aus so und ja ich weiß
jetzt könnte man auch sagen jungs können
einfach eine kappe aufsetzen
aber nicht jeder junge denn manche jungs
stehen einfach keine caps und wenn sie
dann caps aufsetzten dies noch schlimmer
aus als ihre haare versteht ihr was ich
gerade meine ich hoffe es mal
jetzt war mein speicherkarte voll ist
acht jahre damit verbracht die zu
entleeren weil er so viel scheiße drauf
war und jetzt können wir endlich
weitermachen wir machen einfach weiter
mit folgendem und zwar ist mir dass
sofort ein
allen nur probleme von mädchen bei
diesem punkt gibt es eigentlich nicht
mein eigentlich ist es ja die aufgabe
des jungen mädchen einzuladen problem
beim jungen mann wird ein problem von
mädchen gibt's nicht ist geil es sei
denn vielleicht haben manche mädchen
schlechtes gewissen
was ich allerdings nicht glauben
schreibt es einfach mal in die
kommentare ab ein schlechtes gewissen
dann jetzt kommt bestimmt ja wir haben
ein sehr schlechtes gewissen oder ein
echtes immer so ach nein du brauchst
nicht eine art bietet hat mich ein
mittel habe ich in acht quatsch ich kann
auch selber zahlen kann ich nicht mit
das wäre doch ganz nötig gewesen
dankeschön du wirklich so leicht und
jetzt kommt's mir wirklich zu einem
punkt da habe ich mir gedacht alex das
ist ein wirklich sehr guter punkt den
musst du auf jeden fall mal ansprechen
und zwar in die meisten wissen es ja die
mädchen haben einmal alle 28 tage oder
alle 31 tage oder alle 22 tage irgendwie
so hat man als mädchen als frau hat
seine tage und das tut ja ziemlich will
und das ist ein problem vieler mädchen
weil es bei vielen wohl ziemlich doll
weh tut leute nehmt das video bitte
nicht so ernst ich meine ist jetzt nicht
so also ich kann es natürlich komplett
nachvollziehen dass das nervig ist soll
man öfter mal aufs klo muss es wehtut
irgendwas daraus läuft aber wir als
jungs wir haben auch aufgaben
ich meine wer macht denn bitte wie soll
ich das nicht
du hast auch jüngere zuschauer alex okay
also angenommen
jungs und mädchen kommen zusammen und
verbinden sich auf einer verkehrs linie
die aber nicht den deutschen
verkehrsregeln entspricht was ich da
wirklich wirklich immer nur wiederholen
kann verhütung ist das a und o mit 13
schwanger zu werden ist nicht gut das
ist nicht gut das ist auf keinen fall ja
förderlich so dann gibt es zum beispiel
das kondom und wenn dann der
geschlechtsakt vollzogen ist der macht
es den weg macht es ihr oder machen dass
wir so das ist das problem der jungs
oder wenn jungs zum höhepunkt kommt wer
macht es den weg macht es ihr oder
macher des viacom das ist jetzt alles
sehr weit her gegriffen
versteht ihr das ist dann vielleicht so
das kleine problem der jungs okay seit
deutlich schlimmer dran mit euren tagen
ich weiß ja was
das waren jetzt einfach mal ein paar
probleme wie schon eben gesagt lasst auf
jeden fall mein daumen nach oben da ich
würd sagen weil 15.000 likes mache ich
das noch mal das ich das ein bisschen
vergleich schreibt weitere probleme von
mädchen und jungs in die kommentare
ich bin sehr gespannt liegt mir das
durch folgt mir auf jeden fall bei
snapshot da heißt ich so oder bei
instagram geistig so würde mich sehr
freuen
wir sehen uns morgen wieder beim ein
video haut drei leute abonnieren nicht
vergessen und haut rein hab ich gerade
schon gesagt da verpisst euch